willkommen zurück
[Musik]
willkommen zurück zu till Reiners das
bin ich
regt sich über Bürokratie in Deutschland
auf was bisher geschah ich mache durch
morgen früh um 7 Uhr muss ich in Spandau
9 Perso beantragen und habe ich mich
kurz mal aufgeregt über die Bürokratie
in Deutschland Grund 1 war der krasse
Personalmangel rund 2 die mangelhafte
Digitalisierung und da sind wir auch
schon bei Grund Nummer 3 warum
Bürokratie alles blockiert Datenschutz
als den Studierenden 2022 lächerliche
200 € für steigende Heizkosten
versprochen wurden war ein Problem man
musste erstmal Name Adresse E-Mail und
Kontonummer von denen haben da wurde
dann 6 Monate lang an einer
Internetseite gebastelt bei der
Studierende das angeben konnten wenn du
das Gefühl hast der Staat weiß zu viel
über mich weil er deinen Namen adresse
e-mail und Kontonummer hat dann zeige
ich Dir jetzt auf deinem Handy 20 Apps
die du Berechtigung haben jederzeit auf
das Mikro zugreifen und du bist nicht
alleine ich bekomme übrigens
komischerweise seit einigen Tagen Wurst
zum Kuscheln eingeteilt was soll ich
sagen dieser Schinken hier überzeugt
mich weil dann Algorithmus wir machen
uns komplett nackt für dubiose Firmen
aber der Staat darf nicht mal unsere
E-Mail-Adresse wissen oder was ja ich
bin absolut dafür dass der Staat uns vor
Firmen schützt die all unsere Daten
verkaufen und der Staat soll natürlich
nicht alles von mir wissen aber
Datenschutz wird zu oft als Ausrede
benutzt für das eigentliche Problem
nämlich dass Mantra der deutschen alles
soll so bleiben wie es ist CDU als
Lebenseinstellung wenn das Tempo der
Digitalisierung von Schulen so bleibt
haben wir erst 20034 an allen Schulen
digitale Endgeräte in 11 Jahren es würde
nur ein paar Wochen dauern jede Schule
mit einer Wurst Kabeltrommel
auszustarten alle Krisen der letzten
Jahre zeigen doch wir müssen uns
schneller auf die Welt einstellen wenn
Krieg ausbricht wenn ein Virus ausbricht
wenn die fucking Welt untergeht aber
unsere Bürokratie erschwert zum Beispiel
auch die Klimawende ich spiel das jetzt
mal nach wie das läuft wenn ich zum
Beispiel in Baden-Württemberg drei
Windräder bauen will und falls ihr euch
fragt warum ich so viel Spielsteine mit
dabei habe ich sag mal so wenn ihr das
Angebot habt für 1000 Steine auf dem
Kindergeburtstag aufzutreten lohnt es
sich das Kleingedruckte zu lesen so
Windräder Fläche habe ich Material habe
ich kann losgehen von wegen bevor ich
überhaupt anfangen darf muss ich ein
paar Anträge ausfüllen und da denke ein
paar Zettel ausfüllen ja ist ja schnell
gemacht ist ja sowie Auto anmelden nee
ist wie Autofabrik anmelden hier das
muss vorher alles da sein damit ich so
ein Windrad aufstellen darf das hier ist
die To-Do-Liste des Landes
Baden-Württemberg da stehen dann so
Sachen drauf wie hier mein best of
Angaben zur Auswirkung auf das
Erscheinungsbild von Kulturdenkmal oder
hier Antrag auf Waldumwandlung bezogen
auf den anlagenstand oder hier auch ein
Liebling von mir Schattenwurf Prognose
oder hier äh Angaben zur optisch
bedrängenden Wirkung was für mich nach
bodyshaming für Windräder klingt Angaben
zur optisch Bedrängung und Wirkung oh
das Ding da das so nah da müssen wir
erstmal gucken ob ich das bedrängt
wisst ihr wie Leute aus der Stadt das
nennen wenn man etwas unschönes vor der
Nase hat statt und wisst ihr wie man
Schatten Wurf nennt ich wohne im ersten
Stock schattenwurfprognose 100 % für den
Antrag für drei Windräder ist wie viel
Papierkram erzeugt worden
36.000 Seiten das ist kein Scheiß ich
habe extra noch mal nachgeguckt das ist
so viel
für den Wertpapier könnte man schon
wieder eine eigene schattenwurfprognose
machen und es dauert sieben bis acht
Jahre drei Windräder aufzustellen und
wenn irgendwas in deutschland droht
schnell zu gehen gibt es ja zum Glück
noch den Föderalismus 16 Bundesländer
sie zu knechten Beispiel es gibt eine
Bauvorschrift für Seilbahn von der EU
ist okay wer will nicht eine
einheitliche Seilbahn wenn ich als
Slowake nicht die gleichen Seilbahn habe
wie ein Portugal könnte sein dass ich
von Nervosität rausspringe Deutschland
muss also wie alle Staaten diese
Richtlinie umsetzen das ist ein bisschen
speziell aber okay soweit aber die
Umsetzung der Richtlinie fällt in die
Kompetenz der Länder jedes einzelne der
16 Bundesländer in Deutschland muss
jetzt ein einzelnes Gesetz für den Bau
und Betrieb von Seilbahn erlassen das
Seilbahn Land Hamburg z.B oder
Schleswig-Holstein oder Brandenburg klar
da kann man jetzt bisher keine Seilbahn
bauen weil da keine Berge sind aber die
brauchen trotzdem alle ein
seilbahngesetz ich sag mal so wenn jetzt
plötzlich da Berge entstehen Hamburg ist
vorbereitet
Bürokratie ist mal gedacht worden als
großer Gleichmacher ein Mechanismus der
alle gleich behandelt also unabhängig
davon wer etwas möchte niemand wird
besser oder schlechter behandelt das ist
eine tolle Idee aber Moment ist es
einfach nur für alle gleich Scheiße
deshalb so ist ja niemand profitiert
davon alle produzieren einfach nur tote
Zeit am Fließband
ja und mittlerweile schon wieder hell
Leute wünsch mir Glück mit dem Perso und
dieses Video hier bleibt unser kleines
Geheimnis ich hoffe dass niemand in der
Berliner Verwaltung das jemals sieht
sonst bekomme ich nie wieder einen
Termin
so Leute wir haben hier unbürokratisch
für euch einiges möglich gemacht zum
Beispiel hier den Kanal zu liken zu
abonnieren unten drunter könnt ihr
einfach schreiben was ihr so mit dem
Behörden erlebt habt nur ein Beispiel ja
und wenn es nicht macht können wir das
aber auch ganz schnell wieder ändern ja
dann dürfte das nächste Video nur sehen
wenn ihr ein Formular ausfüllt für die
Humor Verträglichkeitsprüfung
Internetführerschein dann noch ein Foto
beilegt für die Prüfung der optisch
bringt und Wirkung und 12 € im
Briefmarken beilegen zack in 18 Wochen
schicken wir euch dann eine VHS-Kassette
so und bitte